so
ski is not me
walking through him not me walking
through him
but it's not me stopping sick
zombies talking here
so i'll throw it on his torso so
i'm not going like this
so same thing on his face you see i'm
closer
not walking through
but not punching two
punching through boom
boom
so that's what he's doing so he's
much closer than katatsu dodie
okay so i'm in here
i have to respond to this so
up
an immediate connection onto his body
is not after his punches out because
that punch would be possible
so as it's coming up
connection on his body body through his
arm
to his body through his arm to your body
you're gonna need the eye you can't just
smack these things
[Music]
then you'll feel it start to well it
starts to lose
and get to about 6 30
or in this case 5 35 then it goes
in
[Music]
he's adhering
then the head is this the head will pick
up
the head right now is yin this is yong
yin but they're to switch places home
ahead
don't shut the head down at the start
wait for the arm to go
in then the head will go yawn
then you'll feel the head arm start out
can't do anything
it wouldn't hit again and now the other
hand can go
[Music]
on
okay
so uh push push so
if i want to project it from here this
whole body
his whole body let me do another one
all right kiss one body
do another one his whole body
same thing as if i get to hear his whole
body
hold on
if i get him
oh
it's not just some of his arms it's not
just
[Music]
so he sees he's got to penetrate enough
and solid enough
so i've moved out of the way but it's
not in his arm
it's in this whole point
[Music]
all right we'll go here don't move
forward
it's his whole body
[Music]
so this whole body can move this way
then i can start to get it down
[Music]
i like this not in his arm
resist okay he's not coming with me he's
he's now anti-punching he's got his
fists out
but he's pulling back okay that makes ik
he's more
and now i have to turn i have to twist
him
okay i got two points of contact
here that that's the content this this
is not the kite
forward up there it is and now two
points
so this point full body
together hold on
not
whole body
[Music]
he goes i don't care this
this is still doing it i'm still in the
clock
still in this car still in this spot not
not torquing low you see all that slack
did you see it
it's all slide it's all slapping
in his body where i'm touching
where i'm touching it wherever i'm
touching i'm touching his center
i don't
that's all slack all movement no effect
on the center
okay to to use the arm you have to be
closer you have to do a multi you can't
do it
okay you have to be closer you can see
i'm in here then
then i got torque then i can use
that's not what we're doing
can you see i'm not grabbing
is all wasted energy where i am
where i am well that moves that was